i think that the best murder mysteries
also have the element of psychological
thriller i think they must genuinely
scare you so sometimes they have the
element of a horror film i think they
have to be continually suspenseful i
think they have to present in the
audience however glamorous the location
or the nature of the story they have to
drip feed a sense of dread a sense that
whatever enjoyment and interplay between
the characters is being had that there
is no parlor game at play here there is
the very very serious issue of murder
and that prospect and the prospect that
any one of you at any time
any character could be subject to that
terrible fate i think needs to be
constantly unsettlingly agitatedly there
[Music]
agatha christie often puts her
characters in these sort of gilded cages
in death on the nile the karnak and nile
steamer is a luxurious
confined claustrophobic space where the
wedding party that enters with a dozen
glamorous people all coming to enjoy
themselves suddenly find that it's a
dangerous space where murder occurs
where people are hiding where lies are
being told and so we were able to create
the space and the splendor the
craftsmanship the detail whether it's in
cutlery or glasses or lights or in the
amount of openness to the river and the
great sites of ancient egypt that are
out there we were able really able to
construct something so beautiful
something that as soon as our film
audience saw it you would want to be
part of and in fact when we shot this we
didn't even show it to our cast until we
filmed them getting on the boat for the
first time
so we wanted to have this feeling of
gosh what an exciting place to be
until that exciting place turns out to
be what a dangerous place to be and
agatha christie i think does that
constant back and forth between what
appears to be safe and what appears to
be dangerous and death on the nile plays
with that dynamic at all
i have times
many crimes
but this policy of truth
has all taught the shape of my soul i
think just from the agatha christie
universe it would be great to see her
kilpoiro and miss marple get together
i think if they were able to travel in
time having them meet at a club in
london with sherlock holmes would be
pretty interesting because i think they
both think that they're the cleverest
man in the room
so it would be interesting to see how
they pretended they weren't i think
they're both capable of being very sort
of chameleon-like in the way they
present themselves depending on the
situation i think in the world of sort
of superhero assembly i think there are
a couple of detective match-ups that
would be
fun that would be fun for starters
sherlock ercule and jane marple
i'll have grounds
more relative than this
the play is the thing
wherein i'll catch the conscience
of the king
i had been involved with the play hamlet
ever since i saw richard chamberlin the
great american actor on television and
then derrick jacoby on stage in england
when i was a very young man and was
always intrigued by this extraordinary
character who's at the center of a
revenge drama
and all across my early acting career i
got a chance to play the role so by the
time i got to the age of 34 35 i had
enormous amount of experience of working
on the play in the park
and a real determination to try and
present the whole of the text of hamlet
in as far as we know it in the most sort
of spectacularly cinematic way one could
so i worked with castle rock and an
amazing cast of actors with derek jacoby
playing the king this time not the
prince uh and people like charlton
heston and julie christie and gerard
deputy and jack lemmon and robin
williams and kate winslet making an
early appearance just before she went
and did titanic and for me it was about
it was about doing a film that concerned
uh the life of one family a royal family
but whose own story when it unfolds with
such tragic consequences
really changes the fate of nations and
so by the end of the story
there's been a revolution and yet at
this at the center of it is you might
say a quite simple account of the
necessity to grieve when we lose people
because that grieving doesn't happen a
chain of events is set in motion that
creates a great story full of fights
drama love passion intrigue an amazing
work of art from shakespeare and in this
case the chance to do and 70 millimeter
with castle rock was really one of the
great great privileges of my
professional life you're thinking only
as a warrior this was an act of war was
the act of but a few doomed to fail look
how far they got we will find the breach
in our defenses and it will be sealed as
king of asgard but you're not king
not yet
i got the job as the director of the
first thor film because kevin feige knew
that i was not particularly intimidated
by the more heightened elements of the
story that at one stage would have
men in tights riding horses over a
rainbow bridge in space if you could
make that work then maybe the story was
going to work and so i relished that
opportunity of balancing the tone
between something like that and then
bringing the banished thor a thor
banished because of his rebellious
relationship to a stern father and a
jealous brother banished to earth and
then
the movie allowing for a comic tone that
plays around the idea of the fish out of
water that is the hulking thor in new
mexico and having to deal with the
perplexed but brilliant jane foster
played by natalie portman the chance to
create the beginning of the world of
asgard in the world of the nine realms
and everything that subsequent films
might explore
was a kind of shakespearean
tapestry that i relished and wasn't
thrown by i felt as though no you can be
dramatic and you can be funny you'd be
silly and you could be earnest and all
of those things are the glory of
something like thor and that part of the
glory of the mixture of things that
you'll find in so many parts of the mcu
so to be to be asked to be at the
beginning of what we did not know was
then going to become you know one of the
greatest cinematic phenomenon of the
21st century that that was a real it was
a career high
whatever happens
what you've done with easter
it's phenomenal
the story of belfast was one that was
born out of the beginnings of the
pandemic and the introspection that it
brought that sent me in this time of
uncertainty and an unknown future back
to my time as a nine-year-old in belfast
where that same atmosphere was
experienced when suddenly violence
visited our otherwise very harmonious
street
and the whole world turned upside down
much as it did for us
all across the world in these last two
or three years and
i wanted to write about how a
nine-year-old with a nine-year-old's
view of things so inexperienced and
beginning to understand how difficult it
is to be a grown-up in a world that is
so
uh volatile i wanted to sort of chart
that and in so doing look at the
sacrifices my parents made to help us
judge whether to stay or to leave in a
difficult situation that was was
particular for every single family and
to
put a spotlight on some of the
surprising things that went with that
terribly violent time which was the
amount of laughter and humor and love
and song and dance and all the coping
mechanisms that helped ordinary families
put one foot in front of the other
at a time of sort of traumatic change it
was a one of those sort of films that
had to be written and then uh once my
family approved of it which thank god
they did it then felt as though
it was important to try and make
something that was sort of written
directly from the heart
and let it and let it play to the hearts
of people around the world
we few
we happy few
we banned of brothers
for he today that sheds his blood with
me shall be my brother
be he near so vile this day shall gentle
his condition
and gentlemen in england now our bed
shall think themselves are cursed they
were not here and hold their manhoods
cheap
whilst any speaks
that thought with us
upon said trespasser
in directing my first film henry v and
thinking about what you would say to
your younger self i'd actually say well
done because one of the things that was
part of that experience was a source of
fearlessness it might have been born out
of ignorance but i guess what it
resulted in was a real sense of
following your own instinct i had been
in the play henry v over two or three
years and many many performances and so
i had a fairly developed sense of how it
might play as a story
and those instincts i think i i because
i didn't have much else to be honest i
had the observation that i'd had of
working on some films and some
television programs with very good
people but i also learned
there that one of the smartest things
that you can ever say if it's true which
in my case it often was while making
henry v uh the phrase is i don't know
when someone asks you something if you
don't know you really have to say it i
would have probably started saying that
earlier if i started again but what i
admired about that was that it was
relatively unfiltered i didn't
second-guess myself and i think i would
give my advice to any first-time
director
that that's that's why you're there i
remember the cinematographer kenneth
mcmillan uh who i'd worked with on a pat
o'connor film called a month in the
country with colin firth he was shooting
henry v
and um he made the point to me said
don't ever worry about some of these
technical things he said you're learning
very quickly and you ask questions all
the time and you tell us what you don't
know and that's all we need but what we
really want is your vision of this we
want your ideas so don't think that
there's some magic science that you have
to find don't think that there's some
magic other place to go for the secret
of making a film you're here because you
have an idea of how to do it uh the you
have the why
lots of other people will help you with
the how and i think intuitively i kind
of understood quite a bit of that and i
don't know whether i would say that to
my young self i'd say it to my old self
i'd say that to my old self now so that
i'd give the the advice to my old self
of you know what direct a bit more like
you directed henry v than the first
movie you made
he's only the greatest detective alive i
suspect you invited me for reasons other
than the fun annette benning you know
said on uh death on the nile that her
best experiences with the best directors
were that they were very organized she
said when i say that i know that it does
not sound sexy but believe me when
they're as organized as i found chris
columbus paul greengrass chris nolan
danny boyle to be the organization is
all to do with clearing the playing
field so that the maximum amount of
creative spontaneity can occur so they
are all directors who have been there
way before you they are spiritually and
sometimes actually up in the morning way
before anybody else in order to try and
answer every question do every piece of
prep they practically can in order to
try and prepare for the happening that
they hope will occur and
the other thing i would say that i've
noticed about those great directors
chris nola is a real example of the
ability to use time in a way that makes
you feel as though you have all the time
in the world he does not respond to
pressure even though every day that he
works on a film as it is for any
director is pressurized that that
applies to someone like paul greengrass
as well who brings also terrific
compassion he's very compassionate and
kind person and so you just feel as
though there is a genuine human interest
there that it that that that makes you
feel very assured and confident and
something like chris columbus when
showing that quality to those young
people in the in those harry potter
films i think was one of the reasons why
they started so well that they were
given a confidence that he had that was
rare and that i've
i've learned much from watching we have
a piano tuned a chef stolen from
shepherds of cairo and enough champagne
to fill the nile i very much uh which
you see in my film of belfast enjoy
westerns i've enjoyed them since i was a
very young boy and i think the
the mythic nature of them some something
of the western is what i was trying to
make with belfast but i think an actual
western is something that i would be
intrigued to try to do i have a little
idea that's been brewing with me
everything is long-term development i
can have an idea from 20 years ago
that's just been sizzling away for a
while and you and maybe it comes out at
some point maybe it doesn't i've got a
few scripts in bottom drawers
that might come back out and they all
head towards that western world
[Music]
you